strange circumstances continue to swell
around the Las Vegas shooting four
months ago here's the latest the Clark
County Coroner has refused to release
the autopsies of 58 shooting victims in
response to a court order did release
them but it refused for some reason to
release the autopsy of shooter Steven
paddock the coroner claims the autopsy
is still being finalized even after all
this time dr. Michael Baden is a
forensic pathologist named joins us
saying doctor this seems like a very
weird explanation maybe it's not you've
got perspective tell us well Carter's
and medical examiner's have always got
to be judicial orders period it may be
in a situation where the autopsy
findings may be important in a criminal
investigation that the the district
attorney or in this case the FBI asked
to hold off the release so it doesn't
interfere with their investigation but
that sounds very unlikely in this
situation well I mean they're saying
this was a single shooter event and they
haven't suggested there's anything
outlandish that we don't know about so
what could possibly be the connection
between the autopsy results in the
continuing investigation that's that's
confusing that sounds like the
especially when the body has been
cremated as I understand so that I can't
think of a reason under these
circumstances where all the other
autopsies have been released as a result
of the judicial order of the court order
why this one wouldn't be what would we
learn do you think of interest from an
autopsy
well it's interesting when you have 58
people died visually seen to have been
shot why do autopsies at all well one of
the reasons is to recover all the
bullets that have been fired and to find
if there's a bullet that came from a
weapon that wasn't in the possession of
the shooter to see if there was a second
shooter possibly would be one of the
reasons the bullet we leave behind is
the bullet that comes from a different
guy
so that's one of the reasons for the
autopsy
the others in some jurisdiction not
everybody is autopsies if the shooting
is obviously causes the death in this
situation in my opinion all our body
should be autopsy and all the injuries
identified and issues will come up of
conscious pain and suffering when
there's litigation for example and the
cause of death are important because one
of the things that would immediately
come to mind may be some people died of
this DMP getting out rather than a
bullet
of course but but in the case of the
shooter I mean we've been told by
authorities he was the only one in the
hotel room he was the only one firing
the weapon and he died of a
self-inflicted gunshot wound why I mean
those seem like the key questions so
what else could they be hot they're
hiding the autopsy what would possibly
can you speculate what would be their
motive for that well the only thing is
if there were some issues and they're
doing some studies on the brain of the
decedent that with all the information
I'm now coming out about childhood
trauma it was there some brain issue
that may have been contributed to his
bizarre behavior and they may still be
looking for certain special stains and
chemical analysis of the brain that
could be a reason that it's not
completed but usually the reason that
autopsy is not immediately released to
the next akin is to do the chemical
analyses to find is any toxicological
reason right but in this situation the
time is passed now since October 1st
that any toxicological examine a that's
a couple weeks could have been done so
it's unlikely that there's a really good
reason not to release the paddock to the
next of kin not necessary to the to the
yeah I get it there's there's something
weird going
the kid doctor button thank you for that
I appreciate it
good to talk to you sorry thanks